il voulait recréer l'empiré romain un
nouvel ordre fasciste qui redonnerait à
l'italie le prestige et le respect qu'on
lui refusait depuis la première guerre
mondiale
la dictature de benito mussolini avait
rendu la stabilité à une économie d
règle avec les annexions de la libye et
de l'abyssinie il avait créé les
conditions d'un empire mais en 1940 les
conquêtes allemande avait semé la peur à
travers toute l'europe
si l'italie houle et étendre son empire
elle devait le faire vite la résistance
française à l'invasion allemande
s'effondrèrent et du sol ni saisi
l'opportunité pour déclarer la guerre à
l'angleterre et à la france
la voie était libre pour les
mésaventures de mussolini en afrique du
nord l'egypte le canal de suez le
contrôle de la méditerranée et le
contrôle du moyen-orient étaient les
objectifs atteints
la campagne improvisée du dictateur
allez lens et l'italie et l'allemagne
dans deux années de combats sanglants
dans le désert
oui
la guerre du désert
la déclaration de guerre de l'italie à
l'angleterre et à la france
à minuit le 10 juin 1940 plonge à toute
l'afrique du nord dans la tourmente
l'italie avait pris la libye en 1911 et
l'abyssinie en 1935
l'egypte était un protectorat anglais
les français étaient en algérie et en
tunisie les protectorats italiens et
britanniques en somalie et est
frontalier avec 14 divisions totalisant
250 mille hommes en afrique du nord
les italiens y avait de loin la présence
militaire la plus important
la 5ème armée italienne faisait face aux
français à l'ouest de la libye et la 10e
armée était face à seulement trente
mille hommes des armées britanniques à
l'est
lorsque la france tombe entre les mains
des allemands les anglais rester les
seuls face aux puissances de lax pour
défendre les objectifs de première
importance le canal de suez était une
artère vitale
la perte de l'egypte menacerait le
moyen-orient et l'approvisionnement en
pétrole
le 3 juillet plus d'un millier de marins
français mouret lorsque la flotte
française alors ancrés dans le port
algérien de mers-el-kébir fut coulé par
la royal navy pour l'empêcher de tomber
entre les mains allemand le 28 juin le
commandant des forces italiennes en
libye avait été abattu par les canons
antiaériens de ses propres forces
à tobrouk des rumeurs disent que son
opposition à la coopération entre
mussolini et hitler avait scellé son
sort
le 4 août les italiens envahir la
somalie anglaise depuis l'abyssinie et
balayèrent rapidement les faibles forces
britanniques
les bombardiers italien attaquèrent
lille forteresse anglaise de malte et la
7e division blindée britannique avait
été contrée de façon démoralisante lors
de ces raids à travers la frontière
contre des positions italiennes en libye
mais l'angleterre avait perdu les
capacités offensives donné par les
troupes françaises en tunisie et en
algérie et mussolini pouvait concentrer
ses forces afin d'attaquer l'egypte le
13 septembre les six divisions de la
10ème armée commandée par rodolfo
graziani envahir l'egypte
ils progressaient lentement en direction
de sidi barrani
graziani savait que les forces
d'invasion n'avait pas suffisamment de
véhicules de containers d'eau et de
réserves pour assurer leur avancée ils
voulaient même reporté l'invasion à
octobre mais mussolini était déterminé à
reprendre l'egypte aux anglais au moment
où les allemands envahirent l angleterre
en septembre
le problème majeur dans le désert et
surtout celui des approvisionnements
parce que vous avez amené tout ce dont
vous avez besoin
en suivant de très longues voies de
communication et donc pour tout apporté
depuis l'italie vous avez un très long
très difficile et très dangereux voyage
elle signifie que pour repérer avec une
petite force au front vous avez besoin
d'une immense force logistique sexe des
camions des navires des citernes d'eau
toutes sortes de dépôt éparpillés à
travers tout le désert
dans la fournaise les italiens ne
progressait que de 20 km par jour et
leurs 340 chars légers
épaulé par 150 avions et l'artillerie
souffrait de nombreuses pertes par le
fait des bombardements de la rff et de
tirs d'artillerie de la 7e armée
britannique en retraite
le 16 septembre la division chemise
noire italienne prenait 6 libara
grazziani n'avait aucune autre
alternative que de stopper la
progression de son armée mal préparés
pour réparer les dégâts et organiser des
lignes d'approvisionnement
alors que les italiens s'enterrait en
urgence la force britannique du désert
occidental quelque peu renforcé
envisageaient de frapper entre les deux
vagues de la 10ème armées italiennes
alors que la guerre s'étendaient dans le
désert la première chose à faire était
d'augmenter le nombre d'armes et après
cela de nouveaux matériels sont arrivés
de loin supérieure en termes de
puissance de feu ils étaient entre
maintenant question d'une guerre d'usure
le lieutenant-général ce richard connor
était un formidable commande ses troupes
comprenez la quatrième division indienne
et le bataillon de chars mathilde à la
7e division blindée avait pour mission
d'attaquer bookbook pour couper les
lignes d'approvisionnement et de renfort
des italiens une brigade sous les ordres
du brigadier selby devais attaquer le
camp côtier de mac t-il dans les
premières heures du 9 décembre 1940 les
forces anglaises pourtant à 1 contre
cinq se mirent silencieusement en
position les italiens furent totalement
prise au dépourvu des troupes de
o'connor firent 2000 prisonniers la 7e
division blindée atteignit la côte dès
le premier jour est coupé en deux la
deuxième division libyenne
la division catanzaro fut mis en pièces
en quelques heures
les anglais avaient fait 38 mille
prisonniers et capturer 200 canon et 70
chars italien
le succès de cette opération doit
beaucoup à l' arme principale de la 7e
division blindée le char d'infanterie
marque 2
cet exemplaire est conservée au musée
britannique du tank abo wind top le char
de bataille de 26 tonnes était plus
connu sous le nom de mathilda
d'après un canard de bande dessinée il
était fiable et supérieur aux chars n 11
et n 13 italiens sont canons de 40 mm à
cadence de tir rapide et sa mitrailleuse
baisa s'était montré efficace
le matilda pouvait encaisser plus de 40
coups directs et continuer à combattre
il avait été conçu pour apporter un
soutien direct aux opérations
d'infanterie mais avec une vitesse de 15
km heure il pouvait tout juste suivre le
rythme
o'connor avait été privé de sa 4e
division indienne envoyés combattre en
erythrée mais les italiens avaient été
chassés d'égypte lors d'une opération
qui n'avait duré que cinq jours l'armée
britannique traverse à la frontière
libyenne et s'empara de la place forte
de fort calhoun zoo le 17 décembre
bardia au nord était défendu par 45000
italien et 430 cannes et les anglais
alors rejoint par la sixième division
australienne commencèrent leur attaque
contre bardia le 3 janvier par un
puissant barrage d'artillerie des canons
lourds de la roya mener
l'aviation italienne mena quelques
sorties avec ses bombardiers cameron
lorsque les chars anglais matilda
balayèrent les défenses 45 mille
prisonniers furent capturés ainsi que
130 chars comme les italiens n'étaient
pas d'accord pour ce escorté eux-mêmes
vers les camps de prisonniers
la logistique rendu obligatoire pourtant
deux captifs se révéler un problème
majeur
e
le général o'connor envoyé à ses forces
immédiatement en direction de tobrouk
il s'agissait du principal port de l'est
de la libye et sa capture permettrait un
meilleur approvisionnement des forces
britanniques sur leur chemin depuis
alexandrie
les italiens avaient implanté ton autour
des emplacements de canon des champs de
mine mais aussi des fossés en titans qui
se révélaient inefficaces
le 21 janvier 1941 après un bombardement
intense la 7e division blindée anglaise
et la sixième division australienne
soutenus par l'artillerie et les
régiments de mitrailleuses ainsi que
quelques unités d'infanterie de la
france libre commencèrent l'assaut à la
tombée de la nuit une grande partie des
défenses du périmètre avait été prise
sans grande opposition l'attaquent
repris au lever du jour la ville et le
port fut repris et 30 mille nouveaux
soldats capturés
le port était jonché de navires coulés
et les installations portuaires était en
ruines
bien qu'épuisé la 7e blindés la sixième
division australienne poursuivirent les
italiens de la 10ème à renée en déroute
et darna fut prise sans combat o'connor
vit que pour suivre les italiens le long
de la côte jusqu'à bengazi les
conduirait à libérer la cyrénaïque
s'il coupet à travers les collines
rocheuses les italiens pouvaient être
devancé le 5 février
ces forces couvrir les 250 km et
rejoignirent la côte
abed afom en conjonction avec la royal
navy le piège se refermait
alors que les italiens se ruaient vers
le sud il se jetèrent sous une pluie
d'artillerie et de tir de tanks 25 mille
hommes se rendirent troupe anglaise et
australienne
ivres de joie
mais les plans de wavel pour s'emparer
de tripoli la capitale de la libye
et ainsi libérer toute l'afrique du nord
des italiens furent compromis par
churchill qui demanda à ses troupes
d'aller combattre en grèce après leur
piètre résultat
les italiens gagnaire une bien peu
glorieuse réputation comme soldats pour
le reste de la guerre il ne méritait
quand partie cet opprobre la 10e armés
avaient été privés de renforts et de
soutien en raison de l'invasion de la
grèce menée inconsidérément par
mussolini
de plus les italiens combattaient pour
une cause qu'il n'avait jamais vraiment
épousé pour mussolini cette défaite est
une humiliation dont il n'allait jamais
se relever
l'offre de troupes allemandes par hitler
ne pouvait plus être refusée plus
longtemps le 14 février les premières
unités de l'afrika korps récemment créés
commençaient à débarquer à tripoli
bien que novice en matière de guerre
dans le désert il avait déjà une belle
expérience du combat
il était très bien équipée et commandée
par le général r ou une rebelle romel
était un homme brillant mais a
probablement souffert d'un manque de
méthode particulièrement dans le travail
d'équipé
c'était une vraie personnalité
il conduisait ses hommes à la force de
son caractère mais s'il avait aussi bien
évidemment ces faiblesses comme jeune
officier pendant la première guerre
mondiale remet elle s'était déjà
distingué il était devenu un héros
national en 1940 lorsque la tête de la
7e panzer il orchestra une rapide percée
à travers la france au moment où chrome
elle arrivait en afrique du nord
le sort des armes se renversait
l'arrivée de rebelles en afrique a eu un
effet sensible sur la chaîne de
commandement
essentiellement parce qu'il prenait le
relais des italiens dont ils leur
donnent à la marche à suivre ce qui eu
un effet bénéfique sur les troupes
il établit une chaîne de commandement
unifié qui ans remonterait aux alliés
les anglais avaient un commandement très
divisée entre larmes et l'aviation et la
marine
mais lorsque les italiens furent soumis
à ce traitement
bien sûr il le prirent assez mal qui en
tirèrent de l'amertume et de la
déception il n'appréciait pas d'être
traités comme des soldat de deuxième
classe
les ordres de rebelles reçu du haut
commandement allemand était de ne rien
faire avant que la 15e division de
panzers et la cinquième division légères
soit complète
en mai ces consignes avaient été
interceptés par les anglais et wavel
croyait qu'il avait le temps de replier
ses unités avancés pour des réparations
techniques alors que rome elle pensait
qu'il gardait l'effet de surprise
la méthode de commandement de romell
était d'être toujours près du front pour
pouvoir constater de visu comment se
déroulaient les opérations il devint une
sorte de nuisance pour ses subordonnés
non seulement parce qu'il était là pour
regarder par dessus leur épaule sur la
ligne de front alors qu'ils auraient
aimé être libéré de sa tutelle de plus
il gênait ces officiers d'état-major il
délaissa son quartier général
abandonnant ses équipes pendant des
jours entiers afin de poursuivre ses
propres activités sur le front le 31
mars
ils font ça dans les premières lignes
anglaises lesquels mal préparés se
retirèrent dans la confusion
les anglais furent estomaqué de voir les
obus de leurs canons de 40 mm
véritablement rebondir sur les blindages
allemand le règne du matilda comme rois
du désert pris fin brutalement le
matilda et le vieux char de croisière à
neuf devait faire face aux panthers 3 et
mieux armées et mieux blindés plus
rapide
cependant eur 3 est conservé au musée de
bois winton
il pèse presque 22 ans et demi et son
blindage fait 15 mm d'épaisseur
il dispose d'un moteur mais barre de 300
chevaux qui lui permet une vitesse de
pointe de 40 km heure et il dispose d'un
canon de 50 mm très efficace
le panzer 4 faisait juste 20 tonnes et
était similaire en taille ou panzer 3 il
bénéficiait d'une puissance équivalente
mais son canon de 75 mm n'avait rien à
voir
chaque tank allemand disposait d'une
radio qui lui conférait une plus grande
souplesse en cas d'évolution de la
situation
les allemands utilisaient aussi avec
succès le canon de décès à 2 88 mm
contre des chars
rebelles avancent a immédiatement il
déclarait qu'il ne s'agissait pas
uniquement d'une opération permettant à
mussolini de sauver la face mais
prétendait qu'il pouvait s'emparer du
canal de suez et des champs pétrolifères
du moyen-orient il pourrait alors
traversé la perse pour participer à
l'attaqué contre les russes ces plans ne
furent pas suivi par le haut
commandement en dépit de l'opinion
publique favorable
ces actions furent constamment limitée
par des pénuries d'hommes et de matériel
pour le haut commandement allemand
rebelles n'était pas un gros poisson
il avait envoyé en afrique
essentiellement pour continuer les
opérations sur ce front qui mais il ne
lui avait pas vraiment donné les moyens
il n'avait qu'un seul corps d'armée
alors que d'autres du même grade que lui
on commandait plusieurs ce qui confirme
que pour le haut commandement allemand
rebelles n'était pas si important et
c'est pour ça que rebelles réclamaient
son indépendance de la direction des
opérations de berlin ceux-ci eu une
conséquence inattendue mais bénéfique
pour les allemands en effet rebelles
n'informaient pas l'état major à berlin
ces informations ne transitaient pas par
les ondes radio surveillé par les
équipes ultra de bitche lee park en
angleterre donc quoique faisait romaine
les alliés n'en savais rien avant qu'il
ne soit trop tard
début avril les anglais furent forcés
d'évacuer bengazi
o'connor qui avaient les capacités de
contrer les opérations de rom elles
furent appelés en urgence de sa
permission mais tombe accidentellement
entre les mains allemandes le 10 avril
les premiers éléments de l'afrika korps
atteignait au bouc
après trois jours de combats le port fut
isolé mais c'est défense tenait
les allemands contournèrent tobrouk et
le 27 avril ils s'emparèrent de la passe
d'halfaya connu des alliés comme le
passage du feu de l'enfer
les alliés se retirer vers l'egypte et
le 15 mai ils lancèrent l'opération
berbitti dans l'intention de reprendre
la passe d'halfaya l'attaquent fut
repoussée
en allemagne remet elle était devenu un
héros populaire il était le renard du
désert qui ridiculisait l'ennemi sa
popularité n'atteignait se prenant pas
le haut commandement qui n'appréciait
guère les remarques violente qu'il avait
tenus sur ses compétences en juillet
1941 le général à jean lèques remplaça
le général web comme commandant en chef
au moyen-orient entre le 12 et le 18
août la 9e division australienne a siégé
dans tobrouk fut remplacé par des
troupes polonaises l'opération bettle
axe avait pour objectif de reprendre à
tobrouk
mais une puissante contre attaque
allemande renvoya les anglais à leur
point de départ
en novembre l'opération kruse adhèrent
plus une autre nouvelle offensive
britannique pour libérer au gru qui est
forcé les troupes de lax à sortir de
cyrénaïque
pendant quatre jours de confusion les
batailles de chars firent rage autour de
sidi rezaï les allemands gardant
l'initiative
le 23 novembre la brigade sud africaine
fut anéantie a sidéré zerg
haouchine l'aic assurera le commandement
direct et la bataille continue entre le
25 et le 30 novembre
la division néo zélandaise affronta
violemment l'afrika korps la viiie armée
l'afrika korps subir de lourdes pertes
mais ce furent les allemands qui
commencent à fléchir en premier 8
décembre remet elle retire à ses forces
et le 10 décembre
tobruk surpris romel commis quelques
erreurs tactiques en particulier en
commandant depuis le front il n'avait
pas une vision globale du champ de
bataille et face à l'opération crouzade
heure par exemple
à la fin de 1941 il effectue à ce qu'on
a appelé une course à la ficelle
ça signifie qu'il avait perdu le contact
du gros de ses troupes parce que les
troupes de pointe était trop avancé et
se retrouvèrent sans approvisionnement
et furent obligés de reculer donc
romaine n'était pas un général parfait
mais il était un général vraiment
compétents il avait aussi la chance de
commander une armée efficace
les forces allemandes en afrique du nord
étaient des unités blindées l'élite
elle avait de bonnes méthodes et de
bonnes tactiques à londres et berlin
les hauts commandements restés perplexes
devant la vitesse à laquelle de vastes
territoires étaient gagnées ou perdues
les drapeaux sur la carte bouger très
vite rythme des batailles
dans le désert les vagues de bataille
était surnommé le handicap de bengazi le
28 décembre
romel pu lancer une contre attaque les
anglais subir de lourdes pertes
le 24 janvier 1942 l'afrika korps
déclenché à sa seconde offensive majeure
le 29 janvier elle reprit bengazi
mais cette avance eut stoppé le 7
février par la viiie armée qui défendit
solidement la ligne ghazala durant plus
de trois mois
cette ligne marque à la délimitation du
front entre les deux armées et une
période de calme relatif fut employée
par les deux camps pour procéder aux
réparations et à l'organisation des
renforts
nous
oh
libéré des rigueurs de la bataille les
soldats devaient alors composer avec la
rigueur de la vie dans le désert il
faisait 50 degrés le jour et très froid
la nuit
les tempêtes de sable stopper toute
activité pendant des jours entiers
le sable fin pénétrait partout dans les
moteurs les dossiers les vêtements la
nourriture dans les yeux et les poumons
les meilleures troupes étaient réduites
à l'état de troupes malades et geignant
à l'intérieur des chars la chaleur due
au soleil du désert et aux moteurs
diesel causait une déshydratation rapide
l'époux les cafards et les puces attaqué
de nuit et le jour des nuées de mouches
transformer les repas en de véritables
cauchemars
les cuisiniers de la viiie armée
proposait un régime d'une grande variété
me fâche et en conserve ragoût de boeuf
en conserve viande de boeuf en conserve
rissolées et beignets de viande de boeuf
en conserve les maigres rations d'eau de
mer dessaliniser était utilisé pour le
thé l'eau était un problème crucial car
les hommes étaient rationnés à 3 litre
et demi par jour pour tous leurs besoins
et bien sûr lorsqu'il faisait très chaud
c'était vraiment très peu le problème
était que pour amener un litre d'eau sur
le front vous deviez en utiliser près de
2 litres sur la route
c'était un théâtre d'opération
particulièrement inhospitalier il était
déjà difficile de rester juste envie
encore moins de combattre efficacement
l'entretien des tanks demandait une
attention constante
ils avaient été conçus pour être
transporté vers le front par rail
mais il n'y avait pas de chemin de fer
les chars devait être conduit sur des
distances importantes dans des
conditions extrêmes les chenilles
s'usaient doucement sur le sable jusqu'à
ce qu'elle se brise
littéralement le sable pénétrait dans la
tourelle allant jusqu'à la bloquer ils
s'accumulaient dans les radiateurs
provoquant des surchauffes il pénétrait
à travers les filtres et détruisaient
les moteurs la bataille était un combat
autant contre les éléments que contre
l'ennemi par certains aspects le désert
et est le terrain idéal pour un combat
de chars
il était à peu près plat et comptait peu
de villes et d'obstacles naturels
de plus un char immobilisé était plus
facilement camoufle abl
pour les chars en mouvement la
couverture aérienne était essentiel le
sable soulevé par les chats pouvait être
facilement détectées par des avions
ennemis et ses machines l'entêté des
cibles faciles depuis le ciel
les colonnes de fumée des tanks qui
brûlait indiqué les positions des unités
à des kilomètres de distance sur le
sable de ce paysage plat et sans repères
il était très difficile d'identifier les
amis des ennemis très souvent les deux
côtés se mélangeaient sans que personne
ne s'en aperçoive
il était pratiquement impossible nous
avions identifié qui était qui il
pouvait observer une colonne de camions
avançant dans le désert mais il ne
pouvait pas savoir de quel camp elle
était au sol vous n'aviez aucun repère
pour vous situer le problème était de
savoir où l'ennemi se trouvait en fait
c'était un combat totalement confus aux
fins dans la bataille le blindage des
tanks protéger les équipages des tirs
des fusils et des mitrailleuses et des
obus et ce à des degrés divers mais même
le tank lemieux blindés étaient
vulnérables à des tirs puissants et bien
dirigée
pour de nombreux équipages de tanks qui
périrent dans le désert la mort n'était
pas facile
un char qui subit un tir direct peut
exploser
mais s'il n'explose pas l'énergie de
l'impact augmentait d'un seul coup la
température à l'intérieur du char les
brûlures et l'asphyxient coûtèrent de
nombreuses villes les rives est utilisée
généralement dans la construction des
blindés britannique était également
dangereux un impact pouvait déloger les
rives a écrit bhl et l'équipage de métal
chauffé au rouge
on dit que les cris d'un équipage
mourant coincé dans une épave de blindés
ne peut être oubliée
le 26 mai la période de calme relatif
c'est ça brutalement le groupe italien
commandée par le général allemand prouve
l épaulé par des troupes allemandes et
des bombardiers en piqué stuka
commencèrent à attaquer les positions
des sud africains
comme elle conduisit les divisions
blindées le 20e corps italien les 15e et
21e panzer et la 90e division légères
autour de bir-hakeim et les tank
britannique attaquèrent la viiie armée
par l'arrière la 4e indienne et la 7e
division blindée furent durement
atteintes par les panzers alors que les
divisions italiennes étaient mises en
déroute les anglais de la 4e brigade
blindée fonds sert pour aider les
indiens qu'ils se retiraient et
affrontèrent les panzers au cours d'une
violente mais confuse bataille les
forces de rebelles ne pouvait plus
progresser
elle se placèrent alors en position
défensive formant un croissant de 25 km
sur cinq
les britanniques l'appelèrent le
showdown il était vital pour les panzers
d'établir un axe d'approvisionnement
cela signifiait tracer un chemin à
travers les champs de mines la
malheureuse 150e brigade se trouvait sur
la route est pris de plein fouet toute
la puissance d'une division de panzers
l'artillerie allemande tenait la 4e
brigade blindée à distance six assauts
furent repoussés par la 150e alors que
ces munitions arrivait à épuisement et
ses pertes augmentent en raison des
combats et des bombardements de ce tout
cas elle finit par lâcher prise
elle s'était pourtant défendu avec un
courage et une vaillance sans pareil
dans la première partie de la guerre du
désert
lorsque rom elle réussissait ses plus
brillantes performante et
impressionnante manoeuvre le grand
déséquilibre entre les tactiques
allemande et anglaise était évident les
tactiques allemand de reposer sur la
concentration des forces
lorsque l'afrika korps se déplaçait le
fer de lance étaient les unités blindées
et l'ensemble se déplaçait comme si
c'était une seule unité ou une division
blindée concentré et lorsqu'il était
engagé dans une bataille
ils utilisaient tous ses moyens
spécialement les unités anti char qui
était plus importante que les charrs eux
mêmes
les anglais tentaient plutôt de diviser
leurs troupes en petits groupes ils
avaient quelques théories sur
l'importance de s'en tenir à des petites
colonnes et en fait ce n'était pas la
bonne chose à faire
les allemands tentaient de s'emparer du
fort de bir-hakeim qui était solidement
défendu par la première brigade de la
france libre pendant huit jours les
français ont tenu sous les bombardements
et ont rejeté toutes les propositions de
reddition dans la nuit l'ong juin les
2700 soldats restants ont discrètement
traverser le désert pour rejoindre les
lignes
pour réduire la pression sur les
français les anglais avaient lancé une
attaque contre les lignes allemandes
mais les unités avancé subir de très
lourdes pertes à cause de la retirer
allemand rebel senti que c'était le
moment de lancer une contre attaque et
le 5 juin les panzers commençaient à
sortir du chaudron par une série de
manoeuvres
les tanks anglais furent conduits sous
la retirer allemande et les panzers
furent lâchés pour finir le travail
la huitième art mais perdit 6000 hommes
et 150 chars
pour que l'égypte tombe entre les mains
allemandes il fallait d'abord s'emparer
de tobrouk pour pouvoir approvisionner
les troupes les jours qui suivirent le
13 juin se transformait en véritable
chaos pour le commandement de la viiie
armée au shin l'aic oubliant ses revers
ordonna au général richie de tenir le
flanc ouest de tobrouk
la brigade des gardes après une
résistance obstinée aux matchs bridge
box fut finalement balayé et richie
n'eut pas d'autre alternative que la
retraite
les défenses de tobrouk n'était pas bien
préparé pour le siège qui allait suivre
le fossé antichar qui faisait partie de
la première des deux lignes de défense
avaient été remplis de sable des mines
avaient été réquisitionnés afin d'être
utilisée à gaza là il y avait des trous
dans les barrières de barbelés les
trente cinq mille soldats anglais sud
africains et indiens étaient mal
commandé par le général sud-africain
koppler sur la vie de richie koppler
renforça les défenses du sud-ouest
promet la taca depuis le sud est
l'aérodrome de l ademe fut capturé le 17
juin et utiliser le 18 pour lancer des
juncker 88
et d'expliquer pour bombarder les
défendent à feu
tôt le matin le fossé avait été franchi
la puissante résistance des indiens et
des positions des écossais furent
submergés coop leur ordonna la
destruction des défenses et des
installations portuaires
avant de se rendre mais un important
stock d'approvisionnement et de matériel
tomba entre les mains des allemands
ce fut un sacré coup porté au moral des
alliés le 25 juin
richie fut relevé de son commandement
par ho ching nec qui pris lui même le
commandement de la bataille mais le 28
juin l'afrika korps s'empara de mersa
matou d'importants stocks et faisant
encore plus de prisonniers
c'était la panique au caire car l'egypte
et est maintenant menacée mais
heureusement à ce stade
c'était au tour des allemands d'arriver
au bout de leurs lignes
d'approvisionnement
le nombre de chars de l'afrika korps
avait été réduit par cette longue et
pénible avancé au shin lac décida de
prendre position dans la petite ville
d'el alamein une vaste région de sable
mou au sud rendait impossible armelle de
tenter une manoeuvre de contournement
en juillet l'avant-garde affaibli de
rebelles effectué à des incursions
répétées contre les positions anglaise
autour d'elle à la marne mais chaque
assaut fut parfaitement contré une
contre-offensive des troupes alliées les
choix également et à la fin du mois de
juillet la première bataille d'el
alamein s'enlisait les assauts des deux
côtés ayant aboutit à un statu quo le
moral de la viiie armée à l'heure au
plus bas et aucun progrès ne tend à
mettre en avant après deux ans de guerre
dans le désert
churchill décida de prendre des mesures
drastiques au shin l'aic fut remplacé
comme commandant en chef du moyen-orient
par le général sera roll d'alexander
et le commandement de la viiie armée fut
confiée au lieutenant général bernard
montgomery
il fut impressionné par l'état de
l'armée dont il hérite est comme mon
père arriva dans le désert il trouva une
arme et éprouvées par les batailles au
bord de la défaite de ce fait sa
première mission fut de parler à ses
soldats et que leur dire ce qu'il
attendait d'eux dans le futur il régnait
une certaine méfiance dans l'armée à
propos de ce nouveau venu
ceux qui étaient là depuis longtemps
pensé qu'il connaissait toutes les
réponses
même s'il n'avait pas eu les résultats
il était très méfiante
ce premier contact avec les officiers
fut électrique souligne a donc le fait
qu'il voulait que les hommes tiennent là
où il se trouvait s'il ne coulait pas
tenir
kilmer là où il est à la première
priorité de rommel fut de consolider ses
forces
ce n'était pas vraiment facile car trois
navires sur quatre est écoulé par les
alliés en méditerranée mais à la fin
août remet elle se sentait capable de
reprendre son offensive
il devait s'agir d'une bataille qui
marquerait le tournant de la guerre dans
le désert
pour la première fois revel allait faire
face à un ennemi qui ne pourraient pas
manoeuvrer facilement et qui seraient
bien supérieurs en nombre et en matériel
avec une couverture aériennes
supérieures et de meilleurs
renseignements un ennemi qui avaient une
meilleure connaissance de chaque
mouvement de l'afrika korps montgomery
partait à la chasse au renard
quand mon père est arrivé dans le désert
l'armée sous son commandement ne
parlaient que d'une personne
romel il a fait un énorme travail pour
leur expliquer qu'il y avait un nouveau
général plus seulement romaine il avait
une photo de rebelles dans sa caravane
avec l'idée qu'ils devaient essayer de
penser comme cet homme le faisais mon
père avait un énorme respect pour
l'armée allemande
il était de toute apparence un
professionnel et il savait que l'armé en
face c'était une armée très
professionnel et le seul moyen de gagner
la bataille était de gagner par la ruse
principal avantage de montgomery était
sa supériorité numérique
j'avais deux ou trois fois plus de
soldats que les allemands en particulier
c'était important au niveau de
l'aviation les anglais à cette époque
avait gagné et maintenaient leur
supériorité dans le ciel mais il le
faisait à une échelle qui n'avait pas
encore été possible leur donc le rapport
de force en l'air devenait en faveur de
montgomery et au même moment
celui ci prenait l avantage sur le plan
du renseignement dans la certitude
erronée qu'il serait ravitailler en
carburant par la luftwaffe de keyserling
remet le projeta de passer à travers les
défenses d'el alamein
en utilisant de carburant pris à
l'ennemi il pourrait ensuite foncé vers
le caire
mais les anglais avaient la supériorité
aérienne et la viiie armée comptait
désormais 700 chars montgomery su que
rebelles allaient tenter de prendre le
pont vital de à l'âme elle à la fin
montgomery peaufine à sa défense quand
il cru savoir où rebelles voulaient
frapper
une fausse carte fut préparée montrant
un sol solide à la place du sable mou
elle fut placée dans un véhicule détruit
près des positions allemandes
le piège était tendu et l'appât avait
été avalée peu après minuit le 31 août
la 21e panzer division lance à son
attaque
il roulait immédiatement dans un terrain
mouillé minet qui ralentissaient leur
avance la division se retrouva sous le
feu des canons anglais et de la r f son
commandant le major général von bismarck
fut tué promelles n'avait réussi à
obtenir ni la surprise ni la vitesse et
dans les jours qui suivirent la punition
continua avec des attaques aériennes
soigneusement préparé vers la première
semaine de septembre
ces réserves de carburant presque épuisé
remet elle n'avait plus d'autre choix
que celui de battre en retraite en
laissant trois mille soldats morts ou
blessés
50 chars 54 canon les quatre son camion
derrière lui c'était une terrible
défaite pour l'afrique à cox le mythe de
l'invincibilité du renard du désert
s'était évanoui
en ce qui concerne la guerre du désert
il est très important de se souvenir de
la bataille d'ahlam est l'alpha elle a
eu lieu dans les trois premières
semaines de l'arrivée de mon père dans
le désert lorsque romel fille cette
dernière tentative pour atteindre le
delta
ce fut une bataille défensive les chars
britanniques furent enterrés en défense
pour la première fois il ne tirèrent que
lorsque les chars allemands furent
vraiment presse romel a perdu cette
bataille et ce fut la bataille cruciale
de cette guerre dans les semaines qui
suivirent la bataille d'al amel alpha
des renforts des munitions et des
approvisionnements furent livrés aux
anglais
les attaques de montgomery contre les
positions allemandes à el alamein le
furent avec une puissance
scientifiquement appliquée mille canons
d'artillerie ouvrir le feu sur les
positions allemandes et italiennes dans
la nuit du 23 octobre
les anglais et les forces du
commonwealth étaient deux fois plus
nombreuses que les troupes et les chars
des forces de l' axe il avait la
supériorité aérienne
les alliés pouvaient supporter des
pertes grâce à la royal navy qui régnait
sur la méditerranée
l'afrika korps été cruellement à court
de carburant des messages décoder
indiqué ramon gomery cremel était en
convalescence en autriche
victime d'une jaunisse le plan initial
de montgomery était d'effectuer une
grosse poussée dans le nord couplé à une
feinte vers le sud
les deux premiers jours furent consacrés
à l'ouverture de passages dans les
champs de mines montgomery l'appelait le
processus d'effritement c'est-à-dire
l'affaiblissement des défenses ennemies
les positions anti char allemande
s'était montré jusqu alors trop
résistante montgomery avait une habitude
que les historiens trouvèrent ennuyeux
avant chaque bataille il assuré tout le
monde que tout serait fini en 2 jours la
bataille d'el alamein était simplement
supposé durer deux ou trois jours mais
in fine et il avait rencontré bien plus
de difficultés que ce à quoi on
s'attendait
et cela s'est prolongé dans le cas d'al
adha mind deux semaines
bien après il déclara que tout s'était
passé selon ses plans
c'était bien sûr faux mais montgomery na
demi jamais jusqu'à la fin de sa vie que
les choses ne s'étaient pas passées
comme il l'espérait et comme il l'avait
prévu
montgomery changeant de tactique et le
28 octobre
il frappa au nord vers la cour remet
elle était revenu à temps pour prendre
le commandement et organisa une contre
attaque avec les 21e et 15e panzer
division
ils firent quatre tentatives pour
prendre le guidon et ridge aux alliés
mais furent repoussés avec de lourdes
pertes
montgomerie avait changé de tactique une
deuxième fois
2 novembre une offensive nom de code
super charge fut lancée précédé d'un
bombardement de nuit de trois heures le
7ème bataillon arguent-ils et les
écossais couper les lignes
d'approvisionnement allemande de la
piste rama la première division blindée
attaque avec l'intention de s'emparer de
tels l aca tir il subir de terribles
pertes de son char furent détruits
c'est le trentième corps qui parvint à
se frayer un chemin à travers les lignes
allemandes et les troupes alliées font
certes alors à travers le désert le 3
novembre
rome elle fut obligée d'organiser une
retraite général il n'avait plus que 50
chars sous son commandement
il avait perdu la moitié de son armée
plus de cinquante mille hommes churchill
à plat avec humour cet épisode la fin du
commencement montgomery avait remporté
la bataille d'el alamein
la poursuite menée par montgomerie fut
lente et précautionneuse combinant
habiletés et chance remet laisser faible
force évitèrent les forces alliées bien
supérieur on dit souvent que mon père
fut un peu lent à suivre il était très
prudente
mais ce comportement était conditionnée
par ses expériences durant la première
guerre mondiale
en premier lieu vous n'attaquez que
lorsque vous êtes prêts et vous
choisissez de mener la bataille selon
vos critères
en second lieu cage vous limiter les
pertes
il est vrai que plus la guerre avançait
plus l'angleterre se trouver à court de
main d'oeuvre
donc c'était un paramètre à prendre
sérieusement en compte
le 8 novembre les forces anglaises et
américaines commencé à débarquer en
afrique du nord ouest
bien que les dernières forces de l' axe
ne se soit rendu qu'en mai c'est à
partir de ce moment que leur défaite
devenait inéluctable
elle devait en effet faire face à un
ennemi de plus en plus fort établi
solidement sur deux fronts les lignes
d'approvisionnement liées à les tenir
les usa ont à main juste la mobilisation
de leurs immenses ressources mais déjà
la plus grande puissance économique et
industriel du monde développé est une
formidable production de guerre
rebelles lancent à sa dernière contre
attaque le 16 mars dans une tentative
désespérée pour tenir la ligne marc est
en libre mais elle fut facilement contré
peu après ils furent appelés en
allemagne il clair fut déçu par son
général mais il voulait que son héros ne
soit pas associé à l'infamie de la
capitulation finale lorsqu'il clerc
avait envoyé les allemands en afrique du
nord
il n'en attendait pas autant d'eux ils
firent quelques kilomètres dans le
désert les premières années il avait
fixé la tension de churchill et de toute
l'armée anglaise qui combattait partout
il des routes aires les débarquements
américain de la normandie à l'algérie
lors de l'opération torch en 1942 ce fut
donc très efficace pour occuper les
années après une longue succession de
défaites la victoire en afrique du nord
fut accueilli avec jubilation en
angleterre en allemagne
ces événements projetèrent les premières
l'ombre sur le court règne du troisième
reich commandé par e mail l'afrika korps
avait combattu courageusement et souvent
brillamment sous un commandement inspiré
il disposait d'armes de 1ère classe avec
les panzers 3 et 4 les canons de 88 et
les choucas finalement il fut victimes
de l'étranglement de ces voies
d'approvisionnement
il dut faire face à la puissance
toujours grandissante des forces alliées
lui-même disposant de moins en moins de
carburant et de renforts et surtout il
lutta contre une armée dirigée par un
chef qui lui étaient comparables
monti n'a jamais eu aucun doute sur ses
capacités à l'emporter
la défaite était un mot qu'il ne
connaissait pas qui n'existait pas dans
son vocabulaire son travail c'était de
gagner des batailles
hitler avait ordonné aux forces en
afrique de se battre jusqu'à la dernière
balle ce qui restait de la 10ème power
division et de la 90e division légère
résistèrent jusqu'à ce que leur
réservoir de carburant soit vide
la guerre du désert était fini
on